this predator should have brought the
plasma cannon and does that mask more
style than substance
the particular predator who arrives on
earth in prey has a ship that's shown a
handful of times mostly while it's
transitioning in and out of active
camouflage it's even visible as early as
the first scene where a slight
disturbance in the sky over naaru's
village foreshadows the alien's arrival
but what happens to the ship after the
predator descends to the ground in the
shots where the predator is properly
deployed he simply drops from his ship
which re-enters camouflage and
disappears into a nearby massive clouds
is the ship on autopilot are there other
hunters on board setting off for other
spots on earth or even other planets
what happens to it after naaru kills the
predator while these questions might all
seem minor in the grand scope of the
story their answers would provide some
interesting insight it's unknown just
how extensively the predators have
explored earth and humanity by 1719 and
getting a look inside the ship would
give some clues perhaps for the best
though prey is more interested in the
action on the ground leaving the many
mysteries of the ship unanswered
naru successfully uses the predator's
helmet-mounted lokon system to kill it
but when she returns to her tribe all
she carries of the creature is its
severed head what about the deployable
shield the active camouflage the armor
the weapons and all the other pieces of
advanced technology was it damaged
beyond use in the fight is it possible
for humans of the early 18th century to
decipher or does naru simply believe
that she and her people are better off
without such strange tools that last
option might be the most likely one frey
makes a point of showing how advanced
technology can be an untrustworthy ally
such as when the flintlock pistol given
to naru fails to fire and when the
predator is killed by its own weapon
ultimately instincts intelligence and
survival skills are shown to be far
superior to any piece of sci-fi tech
which might be why naru lets the
predator's gear rot in the mud or maybe
with the influx of european invaders
should simply rather leave the tools out
of potentially dangerous and treacherous
hands
at the end of predator 2 mike harrigan
is given a gift by an elder predator a
flintlock pistol from the year 1715 as a
sign of respect according to the name
engraved on the gun it once belonged to
rafael adelini while this moment is
mainly meant to emphasize just how long
the predators have hunted on earth the
pistol has become a key piece of
predator law at the end of prey it's
revealed that the flintlock pistol given
to naaru midway through the movie is the
same one seen in predator 2. the
character who gives her the gun is
credited in the film as rafael which
would seem to tie the whole thing up
nicely or it would if not for a few
lingering questions the big mystery
about the pistol now is how it got back
into the hands of the alien hunters
unless they specifically tracked it
which seems unlikely it would be
incredibly unlikely for them to
encounter whoever it got passed down to
decades or centuries later the most
logical explanation might be a pretty
dark one the predators return for naaru
later on defeat her and take the gun as
a trophy whatever the explanation the
return of the flintlock pistol is a
pretty notable retcon of previously
established predator law
depending on what predator stories
you're reading or watching you might
have one of several different
understandings of the history on earth
the alien vs predator movies show a
timeline where the species lived among
humans thousands of years in the past
and the comics show predators hunting
humans as early as 1718.
that might sound like it would line up
perfectly with the events of prey but
the fifth film in the franchise actually
retcons some of the previous lore pretty
severely in terms of how long the
hunters have been around the comic book
predator 1718 tells the story of rafael
adelini a pirate captain who encounters
a predator shortly before his death in
the comic he gives his engraved
flintlock pistol to one of the aliens as
a sign of respect it's the same gun
that's given back to humanity at the end
of predator 2.
but in prey that flintlock pistol is
given to naaru by a member of the french
trappers that would seem to undo the
entire 1718 story from any kind of canon
which means that the actual history of
predators on earth is once again pretty
murky at the beginning of the movie
naaru delivers a pretty interesting bit
of narration explaining that long ago a
monster had come to her land is she
speaking about a time before the events
of prey or after perhaps predators have
come to her home before but it's never
confirmed
there are some pretty big differences
between the predator and prey and the
ones seen in the other films and the
franchise primarily though the alien
hunter still has a lot of impressive
technology it's not nearly to the level
seen in later human hunts this is most
visible in one particularly glaring
absence a shoulder-mounted plasma cannon
that's typically been the predator's
most iconic and dangerous weapon in
prior films a plasma cannon is connected
to the triangular targeting laser used
by the predators to hunt down their
targets in prey however that targeting
apparatus is connected to a handheld
spear gun still a deadly weapon as is
proven multiple times but not quite as
advanced as the plasma cannon the
simplest explanation for the classic
weapons absence is that predator
technology just isn't quite as advanced
in prey which would make sense given
that it's several hundred years removed
from the rest of the series the predator
also has a mechanical shield rather than
an energy based one and a much simpler
helmet and suit of armor than those worn
by later hunters even still it seems odd
that a race that's achieved invisibility
and interstellar travel hasn't yet
mastered the science of big deadly laser
guns another possible explanation is
that the hunter in prey just chooses to
use simpler tools to make the hunt more
challenging
historically predators wear full helmets
to hide their mandibular alien faces in
prey however the alien hunter that
fights naaru sports a very different
piece of headgear more of a mask than a
helmet it looks like it could be part of
a skull possibly a trophy from a past
hunt modified with a laser tracking
system why the predator chooses to wear
the mask however remains unknown
ugly
at the very least the mask suggests that
this isn't the predator's first rodeo
the hunter has killed before but not
necessarily on earth with a spaceship at
the ready the mask could belong to any
number of as yet unnamed species across
the galaxy it's also unclear if using
this kind of trophy mask instead of the
more traditional helmet is the norm of
the time or a personal choice we don't
get to see another predator in prey but
the alien choosing the mask instead of
the classic armored helmet may be some
kind of prideful display
[Music]